good morning Hank it's Friday I have a
100 1.2 degree fever we'll see if that
affects my video making so nerd fight
era I was so impressed with your gussie
manlove hunting skills that today I am
sending you on a new quest to solve a
427 year old mystery starring Ivan the
Terrible he's looking at me isn't he
you're so scary looking why are you
looking at me ok first off when it comes
to kings and czars great does not mean
better than good and terrible does not
mean worse than bad although that's a
common mistake great and terrible in
their classical meanings are actually
quite similar they both have
connotations of power and might and
authority ok picture this I know I need
to button the button you're 3 years old
and your dad dies of a leg boil you want
to know why it's better to be middle
class in the 21st century than it is to
be incredibly rich in the 15th century
very rarely do people currently dive leg
boils right so you're three years old
and your dad dies which means that
technically you're now the king of
Russia which is a terrible gig because
like you're mostly potty trained but
you're not totally ready to run a
country so that means you need a regent
fortunately your mom is available to be
your region too unfortunately when
you're 8 the nobility kills her
so you're 8 you've got all these
nobility these boyars running around the
palace fighting with each other over who
should rule the show and you hate them
because they killed your mom and they
also make you nervous because they might
kill you but when you turn 16 and you
take over the throne you decide you know
I'm not gonna focus on my energy on
negativity on getting rid of these
boyars I'm gonna make the world better
you modernize the legal code you open up
trade with Europe you annex a bunch of
land to make Russia look more like
Russia and you marry this beautiful girl
named Anastasia Hank here is a lesson
from history never be Russian and named
Anastasia yeah so then in 1560 your wife
dies and you think the boyars did it and
you're like they killed my mom they made
me very anxious when I was a child and
now I think they killed my wife so then
you start to be more traditionally
terrible you started really ill-advised
war you have this quasi police force
that goes around massacring boyars and
also anyone else they come across and
then you beat your pregnant
daughter-in-law until she has a
miscarriage and then your son Ivan
should have been the fifth comes up to
you and he's like dad I wish you hadn't
done
and you kill him in your defense you
didn't mean to kill him you meant to you
know hit him but he died but Hank in
your role is Ivan the Terrible that is
not even the worst thing you ever did
the worst was this 427 years ago you die
in the middle of a chess game without
telling anyone where you're incredibly
fancy library is sorry I get very upset
when people screw around libraries your
grandfather Ivan the third married a
Byzantine lady by Byzantine I don't mean
like complicated I mean like of
Byzantium as her dowry she brought with
her a beautiful library full of
illuminated manuscripts encrusted in
jewels so valuable that the king of
Russia was like man we have got to hide
this so they built an underground
library somewhere underneath Moscow
they're like thousands of miles of
tunnels underneath Moscow because it's
the perfect sand for tunneling or
something and that would have worked
fine except Ivan the Terrible was so
obsessed with killing boyars in
expanding Russia and becoming the first
real Tsar that he completely forgot
about the library and died without
telling anyone where it was in short
Hank if the legends are true there are
right now underneath Moscow billions of
dollars worth of books and so for the
last 427 years people have been
searching for it nerdfighters that is my
task for you I have created a thread in
your pants link in the doobly-doo we're
together we can search out information
so that we might uncover everything that
there is to be known about that great
and terrible library Hank I'll see you
on Monday